an estimated two and a half million
adults in this country suffer from an
anxiety disorder known as agoraphobia
now it causes people to stay home to
avoid situations that could trigger a
panic attack like traveling our lead
national correspondent david bagnos with
us now to share one man's remarkable
journey as he takes steps huge steps to
overcome his agoraphobia david you don't
use the word remarkable very often
the story you know how you always say to
me david where are you how did you find
it yes
you all know it does sound like good
people at home are going yeah we know
yes
this story came to us two months ago we
did a story about a news anchor in new
orleans who left her job for a major
life change and in that story she said
something which inspired a houston texas
man to write to us
he said that his agoraphobia had him
colorfully living but silently suffering
and after six years of therapy the last
two of which had been really intense he
said david i am finally ready to
confront some of my biggest fears
hi david i watched your segment with
karen swenson i am inspired what struck
me most was when she spoke about her
husband's cancer diagnosis
quote
when he was diagnosed we looked for the
person who beat it
when he passed i looked for the widow
who was still smiling that was so
powerful
i'm a 35 year old houstonian and i
suffer from agoraphobia i seemingly lead
a normal life as a local store manager
but no one knows that i haven't traveled
beyond a one mile radius from my home in
over 10 years
my childhood was extremely limited due
to my mother suffering with agoraphobia
and my adult years have been no
different since my diagnosis at the age
of 19. you just read that on national
television how does that feel
it feels freeing finish the sentence for
me
for me agoraphobia is
for me agoraphobia is prison the best
way that i can describe it is feeling
like i'm living in a glass box
like there are walls and boundaries that
i cannot get past
and when i
if i attempt to or when i do i literally
feel as though i'm going to die you work
across the street from your house i do
you eat across the street i do tell me
some of the things you've missed all of
my sister's graduations my niece's
graduation tons of birthday celebrations
um two grandmother's funerals my
sister's wedding she sends me an email
right as she's about to walk down the
aisle
in the email she
said uh
i know that you would be here
i'm sorry i haven't talked about this
cecil found an online lecture from dr
karen cassidy the owner of the
chicago-based anxiety treatment center
this year he emailed her while i have
never met you it became clear that you
understand some of the challenges that
many of us face
i want to reclaim my life dr cassidy
arranged for a houston therapist to
treat cecil with online sessions you
have given us a list of things that you
would like to do not things that we've
asked you or pressured you to do correct
but he was not prepared for what we had
up our sleeve
meeting dr cassidy for the first time in
person you are the bravest man i know
right now
i've been so excited to see you
i'm going to be
your exposure coach today
when you're practicing she flew to
houston at our invitation
to guide him on this big day tell her
what you'd like to do so um i'd like to
go to my therapist's office
i'd like to write an escalator yeah i'd
like to go to the grocery store part of
dr cassidy's therapy would be to provoke
cecil's anxiety by intentionally
hyperventilating that this is done to
get him used to the sensation of panic
and learn that he can handle it and
teach his body to not respond with panic
attacks so my goal isn't to make this
easy okay
it's to
step into the heat okay and to discover
you can take it okay
i'm willing to do difficulty
so where's the first place we're going
cecil so the first place we're going to
go is to the mall we're going to ride an
escalator he was last on an escalator
four years ago so
let's do it he'd rely on exercises to
induce dizziness in order to push
through fantastic you are acing this
what did you feel um the sweaty palms
the dizziness the
um
the sensitivity to light i think i stood
there for like three minutes talking to
her two minutes talking yes then it just
subsided next up was the grocery store
now cecil hadn't been to one of those in
three years
he is doing so
it's amazing
it's amazing to be here
lines overwhelm him even the smallest
purchase was a big accomplishment yes
yes yes yes cecil was telling us earlier
how some people will look at him and
think i see anything wrong with him he
looks totally fine and i in the store
had that moment where i was like are you
sure you're nervous because you look
totally fine
yeah yeah and that is so typical what we
see is that when people have a panic
attack usually they're the only one who
notices and unless you know someone well
and you know there's a tell like they
get still or quiet
you wouldn't know this is okay
the next one is the real
right that's the therapist office right
if he can get to his therapist office
that means he could have future
appointments in person so you're ready
to hyperventilate
okay one two three
and just keep doing it until you feel
weird and then we'll start the car keep
going really exhale hard until you get
really weird feeling okay so what's your
anxiety
level right now
yeah how are you doing right now um
i am
it's actually coming down pretty quickly
um
okay that that tells me something really
good which is your body's already
starting to lose its
automatic
oh no reaction five minutes later he
arrived at the therapist's office and
wanted to go inside and even say hello
the next day he went back by himself
my prayer has been to be seen um to be
seen to be seen oh yeah i think that
sometimes when you suffer you feel like
nobody sees you when you deal with
agoraphobia people write you off and
you're often hidden in the shadows we
see you cecil we see you thank you
this story is a reminder that there are
invisible monsters that people fight to
conquer every single day and just know
he's been in years of therapy he was
ready to take that risk he was at the
end of his therapy road and ready to
jump off that proverbial diving board
saying step into the heat that's right
it's good to remember when you sat down
we said are we going to cry today david
you said no you're going to stand up and
cheer so yeah there you go
thank you so much and congratulations to
him for conquering his fears